[Music]
[Applause]
as if yes that is Alicia Silverstone
taking it back to share in the 1995
classic clueless
yellow schoolgirl uniform and all this
season on lipstick battle it is back
tonight
with Christina Aguilera as a special
guest and yes that is Taye Diggs doing
Christina's Candy Man so how does this
show pull off such iconic performances
LL Cool J and Chrissy Teigen taking me
inside the behind-the-scenes battle I
[Applause]
want to talk about some lip-sync secrets
let's talk about when Beyonce came to
set over trying it honestly it happened
so quickly it just she flew right
through it was just like a magical
appearance and then just like that our
little angel just disappeared it was
just fun I would like this to the camera
by the time I look back she's another
secret from that performance Channing
wanted to come in on a real horse but
the loud music scared the pony so they
built a fake one instead
[Music]
stars including n Hathaway get only
about an hour to rehearse their number
on set kaley cuoco who did Britney slave
for you beg to be on the show for months
[Applause]
and Joseph gordon-levitt actually hired
the same choreographer Janet Jackson
used for Rhythm Nation when Anna
Kendrick came out and did the JLo and
then JLo came yeah why do we what did we
not see that day you didn't see JLo
roll-up with her entourage and get made
up and hit super sexy and you didn't see
and I out there rocking I mean you know
it was just what it was
[Applause]
when gigi hadid came out with the
Backstreet Boys I could not love more
and they were in those little pods I
remember it like oh yes we'd like Gigi
had been at their birthday party or they
were at her birthday party or something
and then she asked them if she could do
their song and they were like no we want
to come on and and I think so we got
stuck in a blossom we got stuck in their
little pot I remember her at like I
guess where that was so much fun
[Music]
you